we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 315
area code caller from 315 what's your
name and where are you calling from hi
this is Jay I'm calling from upstate New
York great what's on your mind my
question has to do with Trump speech to
Congress specifically health care okay
you spent several minutes in saying how
the ACA is a failure but said almost
nothing about his plan to replace it at
least not in the speech so far as I saw
yeah they want to replace it with things
like a flat tax credit or a health
savings account and if you actually do
the math it doesn't work for nearly
everyone that alienates poor people
specifically poor people with health
problems my question is just how
vulnerable is the ACA and locking coders
like me do to protect it well i think
that there's a reason that the
Affordable Care Act repeal has slowed
down drastically and we've already heard
from some Republicans you know this
could take a year this could take longer
than a year the provisions are very
popular and there's confusion amongst a
lot of voters they a lot of voters don't
get that Obamacare is the same thing as
the Affordable Care Act but when we look
at the provision yeah everything but the
mandate both the business must provide
two employees mandate if they have more
than 50 employees and the individual
mandate everything other than that is
popular with americans and that crosses
party lines of course you need the
mandate in order to make it affordable
that's how you spread out the risk pool
enough where you can actually make the
whole thing affordable so i think
there's a couple things number one this
is an area because governor's must be
understanding that they will be
vulnerable if their constituents in
their state lose coverage because of the
repeal they will be vulnerable electoral
ii call all of your representatives okay
this includes the governor this includes
state senators and state representatives
but also the ones that you have in
washington DC that's number one and tell
them that you are at risk or you know
someone who's at risk however it applies
to you right but i think that there is
no doubt that many millions of people
based on an analysis of a leaked plan
millions of people may be left without
coverage under what has sort of leaked
that might be at least a part of the
plan that Trump and Republicans are
going to put forward as you can probably
tell the fact that we still haven't
heard the specific plan is part of the
problem but this is way more complex
than Trump realizes and what we may end
up seeing is a tweaking of the
Affordable Care Act it may be renamed it
may not be renamed but we may end up
seeing a tweaking which would still
probably be bad for people but a lot of
the provisions may stay how they'll be
funded I don't know Pat and let's
remember that Republicans tried to
repeal Obamacare 61 times when Obama was
an office knowing full well he wasn't
going to overturn his own piece of
legislation yeah and now that they would
actually be found responsible for the
policy that they put in place there of
all of a sudden taking a lot more time
on it yet so I think your suspicions are
absolutely right here and I don't know
what ultimately the proposal is going to
be but you can bet that will analyze it
and explain to you what's going on thank
you so much for the call i really
appreciate it thank you very much guys
all right